bonjour bonjour
c'est la dernière grande manif avant le
vote c'est ça quoi
est-ce qu'ils peuvent encore jouer un
rôle c'est c'est magnifique ce temps
quand même le
la
vue le cortège est beaucoup moins
nombreux je sais pas si vous avez les
derniers chiffres
que les cortèges sont beaucoup plus
clairsemés
sur les grévistes il y avait moins de 3%
de grévise dans la fonction publique
d'État contre 25% le 7 mars dernier chez
EDF c'est pareil il y a une forte décrue
il y a moins d'un quart un quart de
grévise contre 41,5%, 7 mars je sais pas
si vous avez pris le métro Thibault mais
j'ai la chance
normalement c'est normalement moi je
l'ai pris plusieurs fois dans la journée
ça fonctionnait tout à fait normal
bon alors il y a toujours les poubelles
sur les trottoirs donc ça effectivement
ça défigure la capitale et ça commence à
sentir très mauvais
que les éboueurs sont en grève il y a
67000 tonnes de déchets accumulés sur
les trottoirs de Paris j'entends que ça
ça c'est justement et on peut préciser
c'est déchets ont été enlevés le long du
parcours ça a été une demande express de
la préfecture de police parce que cela
peut devenir des projectiles ça peut
être assez dangereux donc théoriquement
le long du parcours pas de poubelle non
débarrassé
de Paris entre la mer à Hidalgo et le
préfet de police pour savoir qui doit
envoyer enfin faire des réquisitions et
s'occuper de la la la
police des poubelles quoi
et le gouvernement fait de d'isabeth
Dan Hidalgo sa bête noire Olivier
vraiment l'accusé de faire porter au
Parisien son soutien à la grève
c'est devenu le paratonnerre du
gouvernement là Hidalgo dans les deux
derniers
elle a aussi cherché quoi
est-ce que ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui
c'est manifestations la volonté des
syndicats c'est de
doute dans la tête des députés qui
hésitent encore qui ne savent pas
clairement leur choix c'est ce que
Laurent Berger a dit ce matin en
demandant au députés de voter en âme et
conscience un texte qui juge brutal et
et injuste donc il est il appelle chaque
député à ne pas suivre des logiques
politiques de groupe mais à suivre son
son fort intérieur son âme est
conscience donc c'est ces mouvements
c'est c'est mobilisations se poursuivent
l'interse syndical avait décidé d'aller
jusqu'au bout donc il reste aligné
voilà il y aura à nouveau une intercer
syndicale ce soir pour décider de la
suite à donner aux mouvements mais on
voit bien quand même que le mouvement
s'essouffle il était parti très très
fort je vous rappelle fin janvier ça
avait démarré vraiment fanfare tout le
monde avait été même surpris qu'il
rassemblent autant alors du coup la
veille qu'on nous donnait avait été
largement dépassée le lendemain du coup
c'est le revers de la médaille c'est que
c'est difficile de tenir dans la durée
on a fait les 8 journées de mobilisation
ensemble
je vous avoue qu'on commence à s'épuiser
mais
et c'est ce qu'on se disait dès le début
il faudra tenir dans la durée et on le
voit bien que dans la durée là
ça s'essouffle
le discours là le ton de Martinez berger
est-ce qu'ils sont toujours aussi
compatibles parce qu'il y a des nuances
des modifications dans le propos on sait
que je dis partner c'est toujours très
dur on ira jusqu'au bout ce que Laurent
Berger continue sur cette ligne on est
prêt à aller au bout non je crois qu'ils
sont alignés ils restent alignés sur ce
mot d'ordre
retrait de retrait du texte retrait de
la mesure d'âge retrait du report à 64
ans c'est là-dessus qu'ils sont tous
d'accord après bien sûr il y a plein de
divergences entre la CGT et pour la
retraite à 60 ans et se battra pour
il y a d'autres d'autres clivages entre
les syndicats joués par exemple François
omery ce matin qui nous qui nous disait
ben moi j'étais contre la il est pas
c'est le leader de enfin le secrétaire
général de la CFE-CGC syndicat des
cadres qui rappelait que lui enfin ils
sont était opposé en 2019 à la réforme à
la réforme pour une retraite en point
alors la CFDT était pour donc ça c'est
un clivage mais il dit on dépasse ça et
on se retrouve tous dans la la sur le
mot d'ordre report annulation de ce
report de l'âge à 74 ans sont tous
là-dessus d'ailleurs on a vu je crois
que c'était dans Libé une avec Martinez
et berger côte à côte donc voilà
laquelle elle tient bon et c'est pas si
simple parce que derrière les troupes
les troupes
d'abord on va devant l'Assemblée
nationale volé les images en haut à
gauche alors un cortège qui ne devait
pas passer devant l'Assemblée nationale
des barricades étaient placés devant le
Palais Bourbon Mathis fleuret
racontez-nous que se passe-t-il
oui on est devant l'Assemblée nationale
alors ici on passe ici pourquoi et bien
parce que c'est un itinéraire bis un
itinéraire de délestage parce que de
l'autre côté au niveau de l'esplanade et
bien ça mettait trop de temps à partir
depuis 14h le syndicat de l'une ça que
je vous avais montré avec gagné en gros
100 m donc ça n'avançait pas on a ouvert
donc cette itinéraire bis alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici et bien on
a vu des militants brandir des fumigènes
rouges devant l'Assemblée nationale on a
entendu des mots fleuris que je vous
retranscris pas contre des députés et on
a vu les syndicats passer le tube
racaille de Kery James en passant donc
devant cette même assemblée Thibault
en ce moment même à huit clos
la commission mixte paritaire qui réunit
cette députée cette sénateur on parlait
souvent de fumer blanche comme un
concave mais ce n'est pas celle qui sort
de l'Assemblée nationale oui vous me
dites pas encore sorti
[Musique]
union syndicale depuis plusieurs
semaines mais c'est fragile pourquoi
parce que derrière les différentes
fédérations de chaque secteur de chaque
département ne sont pas toujours sur la
ligne voulu par l'intersyndicat je pense
que à la CFDT c'est très organisé donc
non
Laurent Berger tient bien ses troupes
chez faux c'est plus
plus
donc on peut avoir des
nuances et puis à la CGT comme vous le
savez il y a le Congrès qui approche le
congrès ou va être désigné à
Clermont-Ferrand le successeur de
Philippe Martinez qui donc rend son
mandat donc il y a plusieurs candidats
en ligne il y a une candidate officielle
une femme Marie buisson qui vient de la
fédération de l'enseignement qui est la
Dauphine normalement de Philippe de
Philippe Martinez qui a été désignée
mais il y a d'autres candidats il y a
Olivier matheux qui est beaucoup plus
radicale plus dur et puis Olivier Mathon
et donc il a pris des positions plus
radicales et puis il pourrait y avoir
aussi une autre
candidature celle de Céline Verzeletti
dont on parle voilà donc on la voit
régulièrement sur les plateaux de télé
c'est
donc
par d'autres fédérations mais entre ces
deux tendances peut-être à la CGT
peut-être mais
on va voir tout ça au moment du Congrès
parce qu'il va y avoir des discussions à
mon avis assez assez rude et on verra ce
qui sortira de là aussi fumée blanche à
la sortie du
conclavements politiciens à la CGT on
nuit la force du mouvement est-ce que
sans cette élection là donc un jour
peut-être le mauvais moment pour la CGT
la CT aurait pu être plus offensive il
est parti à zoru plus de pouvoir donc
aurait pu entraîner plus de trouver
derrière lui est-ce que ça aurait changé
quelque chose ou pas forcément
honnêtement je ne pense pas
là quand même l'Inter syndicale a réussi
à rester unis jusqu'au bout il y a pas
eu de syndicats qui soient sortis en
milieu de parcours voyez sur le bon là
il y a apparemment quelques échauffourés
mais la violence a été quand même
contenu les services d'ordre on fait
leur boulot donc non les syndicats
sortent plutôt
renforcer de cette de ces mobilisation
réussie même si elles finissent par
s'essouffler d'ailleurs les syndicats
ont tous dit qu'ils avaient un regain
d'adhérents
Laurent Berger disait qu'en janvier il
avait fait plus 50% d'adhérents
pareil je suis assez fecgc donc les
adhérents mais on parlait de la CGT le
problème de la CGT c'est que les
adhérents s'effondre depuis depuis des
années
voilà donc après sur la suite du
mouvement
c'est compliqué
sur la comète essayons si la loi passe
demain est-ce que les manifs s'arrêtent
clairement
une partie je dirais des manips va
s'arrêter parce que je pense que la CFDT
qui est légitimiste qui
reconnaîtra un texte voté alors oui
c'est réservé c'est vrai une porte de
sortie en disant que si le 46 si le
texte est adopté sans vote via le 49-3
c'est Robert jadis c'est un outil certes
constitutionnel mais ce serait un vice
de procédure donc il se laisse indice
démocratique voilà il se laisse une
porte de sortie
donc on va voir on va voir c'est très
très mouvement c'est compliqué de faire
des pronostics en ce moment où les
députés sénateurs sont réunis depuis ce
matin en CMV déjà
donc on sait qu'à cette heure-ci
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge a été
adopté en CMP qu'ils étaient en train de
discuter des mesures sur les carrières
longues
c'est pas toujours simple quels sont les
points qui sont discutés
soumis à discussion
qui ont travaillé ont commencé à
travailler tôt et donc de ce fait
peuvent partir en retraite plus tôt
alors c'est avantage
ça dépend parce qu'ils ont complexifié
le système donc il y a maintenant il y a
différentes tranches avant 16 ans selon
vous ayez commencé à avancer sans avant
18 ou avant 20 et même avant 21 donc ce
dispositif il existe depuis longtemps ce
dispositif carrière longue c'est
d'ailleurs un dispositif qui a été
poussé par la CFDT on dit souvent que
c'est la perle de la couronne CFDT ça a
été c'est un sujet qui leur tient
particulièrement à coeur qui a été
poussé par eux qui a été élargi sous le
quinquennat Hollande et qui a toujours
été défendu par la CFDT
et mais je rappelle quand même que ce
dispositif
la première longue ça peut paraître
évident comme ça que des gens qui ont
commencé tôt puissent partir plus tôt
sauf que les gens qui ont commencé tôt
n'ont pas obligatoirement n'ont pas tous
des métiers pénibles par exemple on cite
souvent on s'anecdotique mais c'est un
exemple les polytechniciens par exemple
qui sont rémunérés pendant leurs études
et qui
peuvent du coup entrer dans cette
définition carrière longue donc
Elisabeth borne par exemple ancienne
polytechnicienne et carrière longue mais
vous avez des gens dans des bureaux qui
en ont commencé à travailler tôt dans
des banques qui n'ont pas des métiers
aussi pénibles par exemple qu'un
carreleur un maçon
peuvent partir en carrière longue et ça
n'est pas neutre c'est un dispositif la
Cour des comptes de l'avait mentionné à
plusieurs reprises un dispositif qui
coûte cher et qui n'est pas toujours
très équitable parce que il n'est pas
lié obligatoirement à une pénibilité du
métier vous voyez ce que je veux dire ce
que vous voulez dire en outre moi je
rajoute que certes des gens qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt peuvent
vouloir partir plutôt et dire bah moi
j'ai cotisé j'ai fait mes années mais
on peut aussi voir les choses d'une
autre façon on peut se dire les
étudiants qui font un effort de
formation qui ne sont pas payées pendant
leurs études qui finalement font un
effort un investissement pour acquérir
des compétences qui serviront à la
nation qui leur serviront aussi à eux
mais qui serviront voilà à faire monter
les compétences de la nation c'est aussi
un sujet ça le
compétences
le sujet des compétences
pourquoi il n'aurait pas des droits vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ça ne coûte ce
que je veux dire c'est ça ne coule pas
de
gauche on la voit à toutes les
manifestations la rotonde évidemment ce
restaurant dans lequel Emmanuel Macron
avait dîné le soir de sa qualification
au second tour de la présidentielle en
2017 Damien canivevez est devant le
restaurant et comme toujours Damien des
forces de l'ordre important présente
devant la rotonde c'est bien ça
oui absolument et je peux vous assurer
que il y a encore quelques minutes elles
étaient assez peu présentes ces forces
de l'ordre parce que conformément à la
nouvelle stratégie de la préfecture de
police de Paris les forces de l'ordre
sont très peu visibles sur les
manifestations quoi que un peu plus
cette fois-ci parce que les lieux devant
lesquels nous passions étaient
incessammboliques la rotonde reste l'un
de ces lieux de symboles effectivement
puisque c'est là-bas que le président
Emmanuel Macron a dîné lors de la
victoire lors de sa première élection à
l'élection présidentielle vous imaginez
bien que les éléments radicaux s'il n'y
avait pas ce cordon de CRS en prendrait
bien évidemment aux vitrines de cet
établissement de bouche les esprits se
sont un petit peu calmés ici dans le
cortège parisien nous sommes toujours
boulevard de Montparnasse nous allons
rejoindre nos dirigeons en tout cas vers
la Place d'Italie la police est beaucoup
plus présente et encadre le cortège
parisien pourquoi parce que nous avons
croisé un certain nombre de
d'établissements bancaire nous avons vu
également des assurances par exemple qui
sont des lieux extrêmement symboliques
on sait très bien que lorsque les Black
Blocs que ces éléments radicaux
s'attaquent à ces établissements ils
imaginent pas faire tomber le capitaine
en tout cas le capitalisme à coup de
pierre mais ce sont effectivement que
des actions symboliques et là le cortège
continue de d'affluer ici boulevard de
Montparnasse
voilà comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure assez peu d'étudiants finalement
et c'est vraiment la grande différence
avec la mobilisation du 7 mars ici on
voit beaucoup d'actifs beaucoup de gens
qui sont très remontés contre la réforme
des retraites mais pas vraiment de
représentants de syndicats étudiants des
des étudiants dont l'université serait
bloqué on voit essentiellement voilà des
des personnes
issues de l'hôpital du secteur de
l'énergie on a vu des profs aussi tout à
l'heure et ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est une conversation qu'on a eu entre
un manifestant de la CGT et puis
également
un black bloc tout à l'heure qui s'en
prenait à à un abri bus voilà en abribus
qui a évidemment volé en éclat et se
manifestant indiqué que voilà cette
infrastructure était financée avec ses
impôts et le Black Bloc n'a absolument
rien voulu l'entendre expliquer que pas
du tout et que c'était bien normal de
s'en prendre au mobilier urbain c'était
une façon de montrer sa colère et ce
n'est pas en faisant une grève pacifiste
Pacifique en tout cas que la réforme des
retraites sera retirée deux points de
vue qui était néanmoins très intéressant
puisque c'est aussi les débats que vous
avez eu en plateau tout à l'heure
Thibault Gauthier est-ce que la grève
est-ce que le fait de marcher dans la
rue sert aujourd'hui à quelque chose
pour certains manifestants non et pour
d'autres oui
merci merci beaucoup Damien canivevez
vous vous continuez à marcher évidemment
et à suivre cette manifestation avec
Marie-Cécile Renaud rédactrice en chef
bientôt au service économique du Figaro
on a parlé de ces points et on peut
parler de ses points on continue d'en
parler ils sont peut-être encore à
discuter ou en tout cas ils peuvent
faire pencher la balance pour certains
députés demain lors du vote de ce texte
à l'Assemblée nationale donc les
carrières longues ça on a essayé de
faire
plaisir à Aurélien Pradier
ça ça bouge un petit peu
sur les régimes spéciaux ça on y touche
plus ça bouge pas je pense que non le
gouvernement ne veut surtout pas y
toucher vous avez remarqué d'ailleurs à
la SNCF la grève est peu suivie la RATP
peut suivi mais parce que finalement les
régimes spéciaux sont relativement
épargnés
[Musique]
parce que évidemment il travailleront
plus deux ans plus que tout le monde
mais il continue à partir plus tôt
l'orage d'annulation de la décote n'a
pas été modifié donc
si on peut résumer il sentira bon compte
donc vous sentez bien que c'est assez
mou quand même
comme mobilisation
nouvelles sur le statut ne s'applique
qu'aux nouveaux embauchés elle
s'applique pas aux gens le monde déjà
signé un contrat qui sont déjà embauchés
aura lieu si on ne touche à rien d'ici
là
pas avant 43 ans
la question des des femmes et des maires
de famille on en est où apparemment je
pense que ça a été adopté pardon le donc
il y avait un amendement donc je
rappelle le sujet c'est que les femmes
qui avaient une carrière plutôt complète
qui avait eu des enfants donc des essais
pas les femmes c'est les mères de
famille le sujet bien faire le distinguo
en fait les maires de famille celles qui
ont eu des avantages
puisque beaucoup de femmes s'emmerdent
de famille mais les femmes aux carrières
hachées au salaire modeste sont plutôt
avantagés par la réforme parce qu'elles
seront bénéficiaires de des minimum de
pension à 1200 euros en revanche on
parle des maires des mers de famille et
des femmes qui ont eu des carrières
complètes et qui ont toujours travailler
et qui ont eu des enfants quand on a des
enfants on a des trimestres en plus au
titre de la maternité mais comme là on
va décaler l'âge à 64 ans finalement les
femmes qui pouvaient arriver à 62 ans
avec tous leurs trimestres grâce au
trimestre pour enfants comme elles vont
travailler plus longtemps finalement
cette trimestre pour enfant ne leur
servent plus à rien donc
certains s'en sont les murs et notamment
Bruno Retailleau certains syndicats mais
Bruno Retailleau aussi au Sénat qui est
un défenseur de la politique familiale
et qui dit au moment où on a la retraite
c'est aussi un sujet démographique on a
besoin de d'enfants
merci beaucoup
et bien
évidemment reprenez votre tour et je
rappelle
que nous sommes en train d'expliquer de
comprendre ensemble grâce à leur
récessiles les points de la réforme les
points importants ceux qui peuvent
encore être discutés et puis il est
tellement modification nous en sommes
parlons donc de la question des maires
de famille et donc pour ces mères dont
les trimestres ne servent plus à rien le
Sénat avait proposé et le gouvernement à
embrayer à donner son accord de mettre
une petite un petit bonus de pension
allant jusqu'à 5% maximum sur le montant
de la pension donc c'est un petit un
petit accélérateur un petit bonus et ça
ça a été ajouté
je suis une mère de famille je suis un
peu perdant là-dessus mais à la fin je
j'ai une meilleure retraite pour
compenser vous aurez un petit bonus
voilà donc ça ça a été adopté d'accord
je coche carrément qu'on en a parlé
régime spéciaux on en parle les femmes
et les maires de famille on en a parlé
cette question des 1200 €. vous allez
parler d'autre chose
on en est où est-ce que tout retraiter
quel qu'il soit va toucher 1200 euros
non mais il en a jamais été question le
gouvernement a été clair dès le départ
non franchement ah oui ils ont été clair
c'est pour une carrière complète à temps
plein et ça non mais ils l'ont toujours
dit alors après il y a eu un
embrouillamini sur les chiffres je pense
que Olivier
pas une retraite en dessous de 1200
euros non non non non
par contre il y a eu un embrouillamini
sur les chiffres Olivier du sape était
pas très clair sur le nombre de
personnes qui seraient concernées enfin
sur le montant total que ça représente
ça effectivement il y a eu un problème
de communication et quand à l'équilibre
de la réforme on parle pour on parle
tout le temps de la réforme des
retraites là du coup dans le tout un peu
tout le reste de l'actualité et noyer je
ne sais pas si vous avez repéré Thibault
la semaine dernière la grande interview
dans le Figaro de Pierre Moscovici le
premier président premier président de
la Cour des comptes la Cour des comptes
il surveille les contes du pays et il a
rappelé que la France avait 5% de
déficits publics 5% du piment on avait
une dette de 3000 milliards d'euros que
la France reste parmi les
tout à fait vous l'avez lu que la France
reste parmi les pays les plus dégradés
de la zone euro en termes de finances
publiques et il a exhorté une nouvelle
fois le gouvernement a arrêté
définitivement le quoi qu'il en le quoi
qu'il en coûte
à redresser les finances publiques et
donc ce sujet
est essentiel et il est au cœur de cette
réforme des retraits
donc on fait une réforme à la base pour
faire des économies vous venez de me
donner toutes ces
modifications toutes ces mesures
est-ce que nous serons des économies en
2030 ce qui était prévu à la base il
était prévu de
faire des
économies pour combler le déficit qui a
en 2030 sera de 13,5 milliards d'euros
au fur et à mesure de ces journées où
nous avons discuté en regardant en
observant les cortèges et bien le
gouvernement a cédé des mesures des
petits des plus grosses et plus
importantes enfin de fil en aiguille
des manifestants
même le début puisqu'ils sont passés de
65 ans à 64 ans bref au fil de ces
mesures qui sont toutes plus ou moins
coûteuses et bien la capacité à couvrir
le déficit c'est réduit et Olivier du
socle le ministre du Travail disait oh
bah on finalement on sera peut-être un
déficit de 300 à 400 millions d'euros en
2030 donc on couvrira pas complètement
le déficit mais enfin ça reste bien par
rapport à un déficit de 13,5 milliards
d'euros mais enfin vous voyez que à la
base il devait y avoir une économie
chaque année de 15 milliards
8 milliards d'euros de de
laps
on devait économiser 15 milliards c'est
ça qu'est-ce qui devait nous donner 4
milliards d'économies chaque année voilà
ça on oublie c'est terminé on va voir le
résultat des courses en sortie de CMP et
demain en présentation du texte d'accord
il faudrait y retoucher quand c'est
peut-être on a vu qu'elle avait été
largement
rush tout début parce qu'elle mettait en
avant en avant un souci d'équité de
justice de transparence de
simplification on voit combien ces
sujets de retraite sont hyper complexes
tout le monde s'y perd et dès qu'on
rentre dans le détail on s'aperçoit que
c'est horriblement compliqué donc tout
l'opinion était favorable à une retraite
pour plus de simplicité de transparence
et d'équité ou un je vous rappelle le
mot d'ordre c'était un neurocotisé donne
un euro de droit pour tous bon après la
réforme a été tellement compliquée à la
mélanger tellement touché elle était
très au début au tout début mais
dans le social le diable se niche
toujours dans les détails et dès qu'on
prend les les sujets un par un on
s'aperçoit que c'est horriblement
compliqué donc là on n'a pas réussi à
simplifier on n'a pas réussi non plus à
faire vraiment l'équité parce que il y a
pas il y a toujours les régimes spéciaux
ils sont pas supprimés il y a pas de
convergence les règles de calcul reste
différentes votre public et privé je
rappelle dans le privé les retraites
sont calculées sur les 25 meilleures
années dans le privé sur les six
derniers mois sans les primes enfin
voilà on en est on en est toujours là
merci beaucoup Marie-Cécile Renaud et
toujours là nous aussi nous sommes
toujours là peut-être que la semaine
prochaine je sais que vous êtes au bout
vous aussi vous allez avoir de moins en
moins de monde sur ce plateau comme il y
a visiblement moins en moins de monde
dans les rues de Paris Mathis fleuret
c'est le cas ou pas il y a du monde
oui Thibault alors l'image que vous
voyez en ce moment est peut-être un peu
trompeuse parce que on est toujours sur
cette itinéraire bises pardon on longe
la scène dans une ambiance bonne enfance
avec de la musique mais sur ces images
de François Carpentier et bien il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui vous choque
qui vous interpelle et bien il n'y a pas
d'ordure toutes les ordures ont été
enlevées il faut savoir que les éboueurs
à Paris font grève depuis maintenant
plus d'une semaine et la préfecture
avait demandé la collecte de ces
poubelles sur l'itinéraire principal
mais visiblement aussi sur cette
itinéraire bis cet itinéraire de
délestage elle a fait savoir que ce
n'était pas pour des raisons sanitaires
mais plutôt pour des raisons
sécuritaires pour pas que ces déchets ne
servent de projectiles contre la police
en ce moment d'après les informations de
la mairie il y a encore
7000 tonnes de déchets qui n'ont pas été
ramassés dans la capitale
[Musique]
merci beaucoup ma petite sœur et non pas
d'ordure le long du parcours et
manifestation sur les métamorphos
bonjour Thibault bonjour à tous
les données et qui ne les mets en images
avec le service infographiste c'est
magnifique il y a plein d'infos et c'est
très compréhensible grâce à vos bons
prévoyez une mobilisation baisse
aujourd'hui oui on prévoit une
mobilisation en S en baisse par rapport
à mardi dernier je tiens à le préciser
c'était en baisse par rapport au
millions virgule 28 on essaie d'oublier
ce qui s'est passé samedi parce que les
manifestations le week-end c'est un peu
différent c'est un peu différent nous on
aime bien samedi on a comparé avec le
samedi 11 février on a comparé samedi 11
mars samedi 11 février aujourd'hui on
préfère comparer avec une manifestation
en semaine et on compare avec celle de
mardi 7 mars mardi dernier qui avait
réuni 1,28 millions de manifestants
c'est le record depuis le début de cette
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites donc hier on a donné une
tendance les services de renseignement
c'était quoi les chiffres attendus selon
notre collègue Christophe Cornavin ont
donné entre 650 000 et 850 000
manifestants donc 80 000 à Paris on
parlait également d'éléments radicaux
mais c'est un autre sujet nous là
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire et
l'estimation qu'on peut aujourd'hui à
16h30 prévoir c'est une mobilisation
autour de 500 000 manifestants encore
moins que ce que prévoyait les
renseignements un peu moins
que ce que prévoyait les renseignements
généraux on voit ces images dans les
rues de la capitale nous sommes à
Port-Royal il me semble entre
Montparnasse et la place d'Italie où
doit s'arrêter ça se fait cette
manifestation alors on y va on
rembour-le dans le dur dans les chiffres
les premières remontées de terrain de ce
matin cet après-midi ça donne quoi alors
aujourd'hui à 16h on avait 272 000
manifestants oui à la même heure sur les
mêmes villes la semaine dernière donc le
7 mars on en avait 706000 donc c'est
moins 61% d'accord c'est ces calculs là
qui nous permettent d'estimer la
mobilisation finale autour de 500 000
manifestants ok
on peut rentrer dans le détail ville par
ville on peut rentrer dans le détail
j'ai je suis venu avec quelques chiffres
je vous parlais un petit peu de
Marseille oui Marseille j'ai un vous
pouvez retrouver d'ailleurs sur le
tête de sur le site du figa comme on dit
en tête de Home c'est ça la première le
premier article en page d'accueil du
Figaro c'est bien les chiffres les
données vous avez une petite carte vous
descendez et vous pouvez faire comme moi
vous voyez ces chiffres alors Marseille
par exemple lui dites-moi Marseille
c'est 8500 manifestants d'accord
attention 7000 sur le site une petite
nuance non allez je vous embête mais on
a une tendance c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être un mauvais écrit maintenant
mais je vous embête on est autour de
7000 manifestants à Marseille c'était
25000 la semaine dernière donc là la
baisse est nette oui à Nantes on est à
13000 à Nantes aujourd'hui c'était 30
000 la semaine dernière là les chiffres
sont bons et moins 57%. ça fait - 57 %,
c'est la même chose à Orléans or c'est
même la plus basse mobilisation depuis
le début du mouvement d'accord on est à
peine 3100 personnes qui manifestaient
ce matin c'était 3500 samedi 11500 mardi
dernier donc là on voit bien une netbest
dans les grandes villes d'accord oui je
vois alors il y a plein de petits points
rouges si vous aussi vous le suivez avec
nous on va vous mettre ça dans le dans
le chat dans le chat sur Youtube et sur
le Figaro.fr comme ça vous pouvez suivre
ça avec nous beaucoup de points rouges
il y a très peu de hausse c'est ça c'est
ça
manifeste un peu plus dans la dans la
Drôme à Vesoul 1000 personnes contre 750
la semaine dernière
Tournus en Saône-et-Loire 150 contre 100
la semaine dernière mais la plupart du
temps c'est rouge tout à fait jusqu'ici
on va essayer de faire ça simple c'est
comme les feux tricolores ça bouge ça
baisse orange c'est stable et versement
alors on surveillait beaucoup les villes
moyennes des villes du mouvement début
de ces deux mois où en est-on on en a
beaucoup parlé à ce micro et les moyenne
elle subissent à peu près le même
décrochage que les grandes villes
aujourd'hui on a de nombreuses villes
moyennes qui qui battent entre
guillemets un record de faiblesse de
mobilisation je pense par exemple je
vous parle souvent de Guéret je suis
arrivé avec les chiffres de guerre
et Christophe Cornavin ne me parle que
de Guéret quand il vient alors oui
dites-moi
1900 manifestants aujourd'hui c'était
6700 samedi mardi 7 pardon et seulement
600 samedi donc la mobilisation de
samedi elle est vraiment très très
faible donc c'est assez compliqué de
comparer mais si on compare avec tout
simplement la semaine dernière c'est
divisé par 3 / 4 et c'est ça dans de
nombreuses villes il y a de très
nombreuses villes bretonnes ou la
mobilisation est assez faible je pense à
Quimperlé seulement
2100 manifestants aujourd'hui je pense
7000 la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière qui nous montre cette carte en
régie comme ça on peut mieux comprendre
et on voit les cartes la Bretagne on va
décaler la souris vers le nord-ouest
et on voit ici qu'il y a beaucoup de
zones rouges Dinant notamment ou à
Saint-Brieuc Saint-Malo de nombreuses
villes bretonnes voire quasiment toutes
les villes bretonnes qu'on a recensées
ce matin sont en baisse par rapport par
rapport à mardi 7 mars
la vérité du début du mois de janvier où
on disait tiens dans les petites villes
ça se mobilise pas forcément le cas dans
les grandes villes est-ce que c'est une
vérité dépassée ou c'est quand même
toujours le cas il y a une belle
mobilisation en comparaison à la
population totale de la ville c'est
toujours assez fort en tout cas plus
fort dans les villes moyennes ou pas la
structure de la mobilisation entre
guillemets depuis le début du mouvement
c'est-à-dire depuis le 19 janvier elle
est elle est restée assez sensiblement
la même c'est à dire que même dans ces
villes moyennes Quimperlé Quimper
Saint-Brieuc etc conscient en Bretagne
on peut également citer d'autres villes
moyennes dans le centre de la France
Châteauroux Guéret Bourges on peut
également citer Rodez dans l'Aveyron on
pense citer plein
ces villes moyennes quand même
continuent de se mobiliser assez
fortement même si c'est plus faiblement
que sur les grandes manifestations du 31
janvier du 7 mars pas encore de chiffres
à Paris non pas encore de chiffres à
Paris surtout que on le voit le cortège
a été divisé en deux et un itinéraire
bises donc ça complique le comptage pour
la préfecture et pour les syndicats on
retrouve dans cette manifestation
justement Damien Canivez Damien vous
avez l'habitude maintenant de ces
journées de mobilisation je sais qu'il
est très difficile d'établir des
chiffres quand on est au sein de la
manifestation on nous demande souvent
combien il y a de personnes c'est
difficile vous votre tendance ce qui a
plus moins de monde et quel est l'état
d'esprit de ces manifestants est-ce que
eux aussi ils s'inquiètent de ces rues
un peu clairsemées ou pas vraiment
[Musique]
alors je peux vous assurer Thibault à
coup sûr et je pense que les chiffres ne
me feront pas mentir qu'il y a beaucoup
moins de monde que le mardi 7 mars
dernier lorsque nous avons suivi sur
figarolive la manifestation à Paris ce
qui se passe là devant les images de
Julien Leclerc est assez intéressant
parce que le cortège c'est immobilisé un
instant on a senti qu'un Black Bloc
était en train de se former autour de
ces fameux parapluies arc-en-ciel que
vous voyez et qui font office de signes
de de ralliement et les forces de
l'ordre viennent de revenir alors qu'ils
avaient disparu de des écrans radars ils
sont en train d'encadrer le cortège de
façon à éviter les les débordements il
faut dire que cet espace où nous sommes
c'est-à-dire le boulevard de Port-Royal
et est assez particulier parce que il y
a beaucoup de de vitrines d'espace qui
sont entre guillemets très facilement
casables des espaces publicitaires comme
nous pouvons le voir ici des abribus qui
ont été une fois de plus voilà
complètement complètement pulvérisé et
là il y a aussi se manifestants vous
savez qui jugent que les journalistes ne
sont pas forcément les bienvenus et qui
cherchent à mettre la main devant la
caméra de façon à ce que nous filmions
pas en même temps ces manifestants sont
assez peu reconnaissables ils portent
toujours une cagoule sont tout noir
vêtus sont presque tous habillés de la
même manière et d'ailleurs je vais
revenir avec cette histoire de parapluie
au risque de paraître un peu lourd mais
vous avez des parapluies effectivement
qui sont aussi tous noirs c'est aussi
comme ça d'ailleurs que les forces de
l'ordre arrivent à repérer les éléments
radicaux ils savent que les parapluies
noirs vont servir ces manifestants
radicaux pour se protéger contre les gaz
lacrymogènes par exemple ils vont
également s'en servir ils vont également
s'en servir par exemple pour se changer
de façon extrêmement rapide là les
forces de l'ordre vous voyez sont en
train de nous encadrer de ce côté là
donc nous sommes typiquement entre les
Black Blocs et et la police voilà il va
sans doute y avoir dans quelques
instants voilà une montée de de violence
comme on a pu le voir au cours des des
minutes précédentes voilà et entendez
ces slogans tout le monde déteste la
police que l'on entend évidemment à de
nombreuses manifestations en tout cas
grandes mobilisation contre la réforme
des retraites ou des éléments radicaux
se trouvent à vue de nez à vue d'oeil
pardon ils sont plutôt entre allez je
veux dire entre 500 et 1000 personnes
qui vraiment s'aiment le trouble dans
cette manifestation qui jusque là se
passait plutôt bien
merci beaucoup merci Damien Canivez
faites attention ne vous mettez pas dans
une situation difficile et notamment
entre les forces de l'ordre et de
potentiels casseurs on a vu quelques
échauffourés tout à l'heure parce que
quelques gaz lacrymogènes rien de très
méchant pour l'instant même si c'est
évidemment toujours le cas un gaz
lacrymogène c'est un de trop mais que
voulez-vous c'est manifestations
sont souvent émaillés de violence même
si c'est pas très violent cette fois-ci
Arthur bijoutin continue à parler des
chiffres
je sais que vous suivez aussi la
question des blocages on n'a pas
l'impression que le pays est bloqué ici
non on n'a pas l'impression que le pays
est bloqué mais nous ce qu'on constate
en relevant les chiffres sur les sites
internet de nos confrères de la PQR
c'est que contrairement au mois de
janvier au mois de février et même
jusque avant le 7 mars rappelle ce
qu'elle a PQR c'est la presque
quotidienne régionale tout à fait ce
qu'on constate c'est que il y a de plus
en plus de blocages de centres
commerciaux de zone industrielle de zone
commerciale d'usine de rond-point et on
le note la plupart c'est des choses
qu'on ne voyait absolument pas le 19 le
31 janvier début février etc aujourd'hui
on voit plus de de blocages de de feux
de palette au bord d'une autoroute d'un
échangeur bloqué d'un centre commercial
bloqué etc donc on voit une petite
changement dans la dans la manière de se
mobiliser avec une volonté de plus
bloquer en tout cas quels sont les
secteurs concernés
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
plutôt lissé plutôt il y a pas de sens
les raffineries les ou les routes tout
simplement oui c'est plus les routes moi
je je
on couvrait tout à l'heure on essayait
de savoir le nombre de manifestants à
Narbonne par exemple et on s'est rendu
compte que le trajet à Narbonne de la
manifestation allait vers l'échangeur de
l'autoroute A9 à côté pour essayer de le
bloquer il y a eu de nombreux blocages
de la 26 à côté de Saint-Omer dans le
Pas-de-Calais de l'autoroute A1 en
Picardie etc c'est des choses qu'on ne
voyait absolument pas au début du
mouvement est-ce qu'il y a des zones en
France où il y a plus de blocages où ça
vous n'arrivez pas forcément à
déterminer on n'arrive pas forcément à
le déterminer mais on le voit en tout
cas la plupart des manifestants par
exemple bloc un rond-point bloc l'entrée
d'une ville bloc un centre commercial
avant de se rendre à la manifestation la
plupart du temps ça se passe entre
guillemets de manière assez bonne enfant
il n'y a pas d'incident mais par exemple
en Bretagne il y a eu un incident ce
matin ou un camion à renverser une
passante qui était en train de bloquer
donc voilà c'est des choses qu'on ne
voyait pas au début du mouvement et
qu'on voit de plus en plus depuis cette
mars depuis l'appel des syndicats à
bloquer le pays on voit les poubelles
les trains qui manquent et le carburant
ça donne quoi alors ça a été la grande
peur puisque la plupart des gens se
souviennent de la pénurie d'Octobre
Novembre suite à la grève dans les
raffineries pour le moment on a atteint
un maximum de pénis autour de 6,5 % de 7
mars le jour de la peine des syndicats
bloqué le pays le jour de la grande
grève mais ce chiffre n'est jamais monté
au sud au-dessus de 6,5 et ce matin
selon nos calculs il était à deux et
demi donc 2,5% des stations en rupture
c'est c'est très très peu il y a
simplement quelques départements du
Centre Ouest de la France
l'Indre-et-Loire la Vienne la Sarthe et
je crois l'Orne qui ont un taux qui
entre 5 et 10% donc il y a un petit peu
plus élevé mais pour le moment
aucun impact ou un impact très léger
dans les racines bon nous suivrons ça ça
devrait empirer pas forcément les
raffineries sont pas forcément
pas forcément les raffineries ne sont
pas toutes bloquées et surtout les 200
dépôts qui maillent le territoire
français et desquels partent les camions
citerne pour improviser les stations
services ne sont pas les 200 ne sont pas
bloqués il y en a simplement
quelques-uns c'est assez sporadique ça
dure une journée après c'est libérer
donc pour l'instant pas de crainte à
avoir sur l'approvisionnement en essence
pour le moment merci beaucoup Arthur
bijouta d'ailleurs ces images en direct
de cette foule qui semble s'être arrêtée
on va me dire dans la réaction on peut
retrouver Damien canivels qui lui sur un
point haut Damien racontez-nous j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a forte de tension
un petit peu et on entend certaines
explosions
ouais absolument bah vous l'avez
d'autant bien d'autant mieux entendu
Thibault que un feu d'artifice vient de
effectivement explosé pas très loin de
nous à quelques centimètres
effectivement c'est en train de
s'échauffer il y a pas vraiment
d'affrontement physique ici boulevard de
Port-Royal simplement des dégradations
au niveau des des panneaux publicités et
là voilà les forces de l'or sont en
train d'essayer de disperser le black
bloc comme vous pouvez le constater
parce que ce bloc extrêmement statique
faisait était immobile en fait très
clairement depuis tout à l'heure il y a
aussi des des gendarmes qui font usage
de leur lancer de balle de défense c'est
LBD vous savez qui tire des balles en
caoutchouc alors pour le moment ils sont
tout simplement en train de mettre en
jeu des manifestants vous voyez il y a
pas vraiment de de tir mais c'est
simplement pour dissuader certains
éléments bah voilà de de passer à
l'action ça va extrêmement vite ici vous
voyez dès lors que les forces de l'ordre
décident de charger les manifestants je
peux vous assurer que ça doit courir
extrêmement vite parce que tout le monde
était statique se regardait en chien de
faïence et comme d'un seul homme ils ont
bondi vers des manifestants nous sommes
ici assez attentifs aussi parce que il y
a voilà des des des espèces de pétards
qui qui qui qui peuvent nous assourdir
pendant quelques secondes qui qui expose
à quelques centimètres de nos oreilles
des interpellations là j'en vois une
aussi au loin de un homme effectivement
cagoulé en noir qui est qui est qui est
qui est au sol il y a plusieurs
interpellations là ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que c'est ici à boulevard de
Port-Royal que la police est en train
entre guillemets et l'expression et mal
choisi de faire sa moisson parce que
jusque là il n'y avait pas vraiment de
charge policières on a pu assister à des
dégradations tout à l'heure Mathis nous
expliquer que effectivement la mairie de
Paris avait débarrassé toutes tes
poubelles de façon à ce que il ne
servent pas comme projectile contre les
forces de l'ordre et bien ici sur
l'itinéraire il y en a effectivement pas
autant que dans les autres
arrondissements et c'était sans commune
mesure avec toutes les images que l'on a
pu voir ces dernières heures à la
télévision vous savez c'est mur de
poubelle heureusement la préfecture de
police avait en juin la mairie de Paris
à faire le ménage durant la nuit et ça a
été fait néanmoins il restait quelques
poubelles qui étaient encore pleines et
je peux vous assurer que les
manifestants les ont bien regardé une à
une pour s'en servir et pour les diriger
contre les forces de l'ordre
actuellement vous voyez il y a aussi un
mix ça qui est intéressant aussi une
espèce de convergence entre les gilets
jaunes et les militants
que l'on peut considérer comme des comme
des Black Blocs qui voilà ce joignent
ensemble et puis qui manifestement vont
essayer de de s'en prendre aux forces de
l'ordre il y a des espèces de de lutte
aussi là-bas entre des personnes qui
manifestement sont des victimes
collatérales de ces affrontements entre
entre manifestants radicalisés et c'est
et ses policiers des personnes qui
étaient là par hasard et qui apparemment
ont l'air voilà d'avoir
d'avoir quelques quelques égratignures
disons au niveau au niveau du corps
voilà ce que je peux vous dire
actuellement Thibault la situation
semble
redevenir plutôt calme mais une nouvelle
charge de police a lieu là actuellement
juste derrière moi ce sont des petits
groupes de policiers en fait il faut le
savoir qui sont dispersés boulevard de
Port-Royal et qui sont extrêmement
mobiles et c'est là toute la différence
entre la stratégie d'aujourd'hui et
celle que l'on a pu voir il y a quelques
années avec les gilets jaunes
se déroule là où vous êtes quelques
affrontements quelques tensions du ça
plusieurs fois par des dernières
manifestations ça n'était pas allé
beaucoup plus loin mais quand même il
faut toujours faire attention à
potentiel débordement je vous donne
comme information
des individus violents sont à Lyon aussi
selon la préfecture
de la préfète de région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes du Rhône les forces de
l'ordre font un usage proportionné de
moyen et disperse des individus violents
qui jettent des projectiles à l'avant du
cortège aux abords de la place Bellecour
à Lyon la police nantaise utilise du gaz
lacrymogène pour disperser les
manifestants voilà vous voyez ces images
là à Paris quelques incidents et vous
voyez 125 images en plein écran
d'Amérique je vous laisse la main c'est
assez impressionnant
le mec il a ses réflexes
[Musique]
oui
je sais pas si vous m'entendez on est en
train et on est en direct donc on vous
dit tout on est en train de s'apprêter à
changer de batterie au niveau de la
caméra mais là effectivement ça se
déroule sous les yeux je peux vous
assurer que les policiers sont en train
de charger quasiment un an et c'est
impressionnant les manifestants radicaux
qui voilà sont extrêmement virulents et
en tout cas pour faire des menaces à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre on a vu
des jets de bouteille aussi alors
était-il
issus des études étaient-ils issus des
sacs des manifestants lorsqu'ils sont
venus dans la manifestation ou bien
est-ce que est-ce que ils sont ils ont
été récupérés dans des poubelles non
loin de de l'endroit où nous nous
trouvons c'est une question à laquelle
nous pouvons pas répondre mais tout ce
qu'on peut vous dire c'est que là en ce
moment c'est en train de voler des
bouteilles vides en verre des pétards
également qui sont là pour un timidé les
forces de l'ordre et puis aussi des
grenades de défenseurs Clément bien sûr
qui sont tirés par les forces de l'or
Dre thémogène et pour l'instant là on
est en train de se faire charger voilà
je vous dis la vérité on est en direct
voilà on était vraiment entre entre deux
blocs manifestement les policiers et les
Black Blocs et je peux vous assurer pour
comprendre l'instant c'est un petit peu
un petit peu tendu voilà
reste avec vos images les images de
Julien Leclerc faites attention s'il
vous plaît surtout parce que oui de vos
images de commentaires et surtout
découvrir encore et encore c'est
manifestations ne prenez pas de risque
on reste avec ces images se fait
gravitel bonjour bonjour
ça se passait bien
au départ au lancement et puis sur les
points fixes des politiques c'est
rarement là où la tension s'exprime
surtout au départ évidemment j'étais là
lorsque au sein de la CNP la fameuse
article 7 sur le prolongement du départ
de l'âge de départ en retraite a été
votée donc évidemment il y avait
quelques quelques Oules chez les
politiques même si c'était quelque chose
de prévu mais on sent chez on sentait
déjà même à 14h 15h jusque 16h l'heure à
laquelle je suis venue vous rejoindre on
sentait un peu de tension dans le
cortège de d'agacement parce que
évidemment je parle pour ceux des aviez
sentiments
peut-être un peu moins bon enfant que
les dernières fois même si on a toujours
cette atmosphère de fanfare mais il y a
l'idée que
et bien le l'exécutif sans tête
le gouvernement poursuit sur sa même
détermination à gauche ils ont le
sentiment qu'il y a eu des beaucoup en
tout cas je parle des politiques que
j'ai rencontrées j'étais dans la
manifestation aujourd'hui alors il y
avait comme toujours ces points fixants
donc je vous parlais avec beaucoup de
parlementaires parce qu'on est
évidemment pas loin de l'Assemblée donc
c'était pas compliqué pour une partie
d'entre eux de venir il y avait le point
fixe des insoumis avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui pour une fois est venu à
Paris et n'est pas resté à Marseille je
lui ai posé d'ailleurs la question
concernant une rumeur qui court sur son
possible
impossible envie chez lui d'être réélu
député de Marseille il m'a assuré que
non non c'était pas son affaire que
c'était pas son projet par
historiquement un lieu dans 4 ans voilà
sauf que évidemment tout le monde pense
à une possible dissolution
sans parler d'un de ces députés de son
groupe de Locus qui a éventuellement un
député de Marseille
évoqué la possibilité de sa part de
démissionner mais si la réforme passée
tout le monde se disait bon ben
peut-être que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pourrait prendre cette place ou
peut-être que le parlementaire qui qui
menace entre guillemets de démissionner
le fait pour laisser la place Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors il nous a dit très
nettement que ça n'était pas son
intention son projet en me disant quand
même de façon très nette je suis en
retrait mais pas en retraite et donc à
l'attention de ceux qui voudraient le
pousser un peu en dehors du cercle alors
je comprends pas des décideurs de la
news poussaient pour partir à la
retraite ou plutôt possible sauf
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
[Musique]
bon toujours pas de bonjour entre
syndicat et politique
ça ne le sera pas
ça fait quand même donc cette actu
parlementaire très forte avec la
commission mixte par le monter qui se
poursuit qui s'est poursuit mixte
paritaire pardon qui se découvre
pas mais parlementaire paritaire
et donc c'est normalement une
coquille se tient à huis clos et les
députés de la nups poussaient par les
insoumis par Mathilde pano qui est la
présidente du groupe insoumi ont décidé
de Live
voilà ou de rendre public sur un
document Google accessible aux
journalistes en particulier il y a 7
sénateurs cette députés qui sont dans la
Commission experita et si j'avais bien
compris il y en a d'autres qui sont
autour c'est ça
députés c'est sénateurs ceux de la
nupette se sont mis d'accord pour
communiquer à l'extérieur le contenu des
débats à l'intérieur alors normalement
ce n'est pas légal c'est pas quelque
chose qui se fait la commission
avoir les constitutionnalistes
Parlement sur la subtilité légale
usage je sais en tout cas que cela ne se
fait pas que cela se tient à huis clos
et donc évidemment en fonction du statut
ce qui brise ce huis clos de quoi
peuvent-ils écoper éventuellement ce
qu'on peut retenir du salaire est-ce
qu'on peut je ne sais pas en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est que le
président du groupe socialiste Boris
Vallot avait demandé est-ce que cette
commission soit
rendue publique j'ai discuté avec lui
tout à l'heure il me dit écoutez c'est
pas normal c'est aussi on débat pour les
Français au nom des Français tous les
débats à l'Assemblée sont publiques
pourquoi est-ce que cette commission
n'est pas publique et donc lui était
tout à fait favorable ça n'est pas
encore un désordre des insoumis c'est
quelque chose qui est très partagé à la
au sein de la news j'ai croisé aussi
Fabien Roussel pour le coup ça pourrait
s'entendre pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
rendre public ce genre de moment parce
que on en parlait tout à l'heure et
terminus là nous sommes en plein dans la
démocratie on a dit par moment on a dit
par moment au cours de la de cette
séquence que le Parlement ne servait à
rien que il y avait des blocages que ça
n'avançait pas là c'est pas le cas là il
y a de vraies discussions là il y a un
vrai débat démocratique après on va voir
ce qui en découle parce qu'évidemment
pour les parlementaires de la nupesse
tout ceci est une parodie de démocratie
dans la mesure où les débats au Sénat
comme d'ailleurs potentiellement ceux de
l'assemblée sont extrêmement
limitées ils l'ont été par la voix de
l'exécutif enfin par la voix
au Sénat avec l'usage de ce fameux
47,3 du 49.3 du du Sénat enfin
l'équivalent et il est possible aussi
que ça se termine
de la même façon à l'Assemblée ce
week-end et donc là effectivement les
parlementaires de la nuit pass sont déjà
en train de dire et ils le disait dans
le cortège tout à l'heure que c'est
votes sont entachés illégitimité alors
quelle est la
stratégie désormais est-ce qu'ils sont
résignés ou pas du tout non non
ils vont aussi ensuite quel que soit
l'issue que ce soit voté je cherchais
les possibilités j'en discutais avec
voilà avec Olivier Faure que j'ai aussi
croisé dans le cortège que ce soit voté
absolument que ce soit voté par
ordonnance que ce soit votée par 49-3
pour eux ce sera entaché illégitimité et
même le patron du PS me disait que c'est
un passage en force pas ordonnance ou
par et j'en discutais avec Olivier donc
qui lui à la tête des socialistes me dit
mais de toute façon même si c'est voté
démocratiquement sera démocratie du
Parlement mais les Français sont
majoritairement opposés et donc là j'ai
plus de mal à le suivre parce que c'est
parlementaire ont été élu par le peuple
alors du coup eux
ils vont continuer le combat de toutes
les façons légales possible et
évidemment ils vont dénoncer le texte
comme un cavalier qui avait une
rembourser ils vont dénoncer ça au
Conseil constitutionnel ils vont aussi
faire appel potentiellement ce fameux
RIP
alors cette
Stéphane peu le communiste qui en a
parlé il a commencé à en parler mais
évidemment rien n'est décidé pour le
moment mais il y a un nombre de
référendum d'initif populaire qui en
fait pourrait permettre éventuellement
de bloquer le texte c'est une nouvelle
manière de
lancer un référendum il y a toujours la
motion référendaire on l'a vu au début
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale ça
n'est pas passé expliquer de
on est encore loin de la fin de fin du
du du de ce dossier parce que
effectivement
populaire expliquez-nous comment ça
marche il faut un certain nombre de
députés de parlementaires un certain
nombre de Français exactement et c'est
le la base du nombre de parlementaires
qui permet de lancer le le sujet et là
effectivement il prétendent qu'ils ont
le 185 députés
voilà parlementaire
on verra bien où ça va pour l'instant
c'est encore assez flou c'est à dire que
ils avancent des pions c'est un jeu un
peu de pression vis-à-vis du du
gouvernement qui a les armes qu'il a eux
on les armes qu'ils ont et c'est des
armes légales on a interrogé aussi parce
que
dans un autre champ
qui est celui de la rue plutôt
disons que si si tous les cortèges
comment dire les choses comment dire les
choses avec on les posant un peu oui je
prends des 27 juin prendre moins je
pense que beaucoup de parlementaires de
la nuit passe beaucoup de ceux qui sont
dans ces manifs se disent en fait le
gouvernement serait pas contre un peu de
violence parce que ça ferait bouger
l'opinion publique et notamment on ne
voit pour les ordures à Paris
c'est-à-dire que là à Paris les
Parisiens en ont vraiment marre quelle
que soit leur bord politique de voir les
rats qui courent dans les rues et voir
toutes ces poubelles qui qui déborde de
partout et donc l'exécutif c'est que ça
peut faire basculer le client de la même
façon que la violence dans la rue est
très condamnée par les parlementaires et
condamné par les organisations
syndicales on a vu à la dernière
manifestation d'ailleurs les oppositions
entre les services d'ordre des syndicats
et ce qu'on appelle les gauchistes ou ce
qu'on appelle des anarchos syndicalistes
qui ou des jeunes la ligne noire des
Black Blocs etc qui sont un peu sous les
radars de toute autorité
et ça effectivement ça peut faire
bousculer
la gauche parlementaire de gauche
espère que le gouvernement utilise le
49-3 en se disant derrière on a une
chance de le faire tomber en utilisant
une motion de censure ou est-ce qu'au
contraire qu'il n'utilise pas le 49,3 et
comme ça on essaye de le battre là dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée par le vote
les deux ont possible et ils ignorent
absolument ce qu'il va y avoir
je pense que n'a qu'un seul
territoire
c'est pas certain je pense qu'ils ont
quand même une grosse tendance alors il
y a eu énormément de soupçons de coup de
fil qui sont passés en tout cas chez les
parlementaires de la droite ça ceux de
la news le 10 beaucoup pas ouvertement
pas publiquement mais il y a eu quelques
informations le Parisien je crois en
avoir parlé de coups de fil passé à des
parlementaires hésitants en leur disant
écoutez du coup un peu quels sont quels
sont les problèmes que vous avez dans
votre circonscription on va essayer de
vous aider ça s'appelle un peu acheter
les votes quand même et ça c'est un
petit peu de la corruption passive si
c'était avéré et ça effectivement les
parlementaires de la news sont un peu
écœurés par ça est-ce que ça fera bouger
la la
les questions des manifestations etc je
j'ai un doute
s'il y a le passage par le 49-3 la
France insoumise déodorait monsieur
rassemblement national par exemple non
ça ça bouge pas la seule qui a été dit
Fabien Rousselin reportage ces deux
derniers jours là c'est que si jamais
c'était voté par un par un parti enfin
c'est porté par partie République et
donc on pense évidemment au groupe
liotte et Monsieur Charles de Courson en
particulier
il y avait eu toute une histoire il y a
quelques quelques temps quelques
semaines et donc oui pourquoi pas en
tout cas ça n'est pas exclu mais
évidemment pas le Front national jeudi
évidemment parce que ils n'ont pas
changé
Sophie dernière question il y a une
possibilité aujourd'hui que cette
réforme ne passe pas quel est l'état
d'esprit des parlementaires de gauche
que vous côtoyez est-ce qu'ils y croient
parce que là c'est très serré est-ce
qu'ils y croient ou est-ce qu'ils se
disent quoi qu'il arrive il y a d'autres
possibilités de 49-3 ils sont un peu
battus quoi non il se disent que DE
TOUTE
façon ils se disent
ils font au bout je pense qu'ils sont en
train de s'interroger un peu en se
disant bon si la droite ne suit pas il y
a quand même un peu moins de chance
et ils sont déjà à prévenir Emmanuel
Macron doit
liée d'Emmanuel Macron
là pour l'instant ils ont le sentiment
que ça bascule un peu dans cette dans
cette tendance là et ils préviennent
Emmanuel Macron en disant même si c'est
voté les blessures provoquées par ce
passage en force vont rester et ne
feront que s'ajouter à d'autres et pour
eux ça n'est pas qu'un dossier c'est
vraiment une protestation de fond qui
dépasse le dossier des restaurants merci
beaucoup Sophie dravid
les papiers à écrire de main grande
journée on retrouve Mathis fleuret
Mathis vous êtes dans la manifestation
donc Sophie nous quitte vous êtes avec
un manifestant on en est où ça avance
pas grand monde autour de vous
visiblement
tu fais ça avec Marie-Cécile
[Musique]
la parole est au Parlement pourquoi les
gens continuent d'aller dans la rue
pourquoi les syndicats continuent à
appeler à manifester c'est un peu dur ce
que vous dites c'est un peu joué alors
qu'il y en a qui sont en train de se
donner jusqu'au bout dans la lutte oui
alors le fait est que effectivement
c'est un peu joué et c'est vrai que je
vais dans l'autre sens dans votre sens
Thibault
ça y est il y a de moins en moins de
manifestants le gouvernement n'a
toujours pas l'intention de retirer
retirer son texte Emmanuel Macron n'a
aucune intention de revenir en arrière
donc voilà chacun est dans sa partition
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ses combats les
manifestants dans la rue le gouvernement
sur sa réforme
et voilà on est à la 8e journée et
finalement on aurait sûrement pu se dire
ça à la troisième à la quatrième et la
cinquième journée on se dit ça à la
veille du vote sur cette réforme des
retraites qui devrait intervenir demain
on va parler de la position des
syndicats j'ai promis à Mathis fleuret
qu'on allait le voir elle est en retard
le voir Mathis vous êtes avec un
manifestant syndicaliste c'est celle de
thé s'il est bien compris je vais aller
de manière vraiment
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Thibault alors oui je
suis avec plus qu'un manifestant je vous
disais je suis avec Laurent du manche
secrétaire général CFDT cadre Laurent du
manche qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette manifestation déçue satisfaite
cette mobilisation
satisfait une belle mobilisation la
preuve que les salariés se mobilisent et
font vivre la démocratie sociale une
manifestation vous le voyez dans le
calme pacifique mais qui est force de
propositions et de revendications contre
cette réforme des retraites injustes et
une démocratie sociale dans le
gouvernement devrait entendre le cri et
les paroles et s'en inspirer bien
entendu on nous signale quand même qu'il
y a eu de la casse devant en ce moment
à regarder d'où vient cette casse
certainement pas des salariés mobilisés
aujourd'hui mais malheureusement
certainement en marge de la
manifestation certainement mais on
regarde ce qu'on a pu connaître lors des
gilets jaunes je crois que les
partenaires sociaux font preuve de leur
engagement citoyen et respectable et
responsable alors demain le texte sera
probablement beauté au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée est-ce que pour vous la
mobilisation va s'arrêter demain non
nous allons continuer nous allons
continuer à porter nos revendications
pour le monde des salariés et à
revendiquer ouvertement une réforme plus
juste et notamment le fait que des
choses sont à regarder mais certainement
pas une réforme qui s'arrêterait
uniquement à un âge légal de départ à la
retraite c'est ce que porte la CFDT et
nous continuerons peut-être
[Musique]
il dit plein de choses il les syndicats
encore aujourd'hui malgré le le petit
bazar auquel on assistait en direct dit
ont été responsables alors ils se sont
battus sur le fond ils ont aussi mais en
œuvre des des journées de mobilisation
où il y a pas eu de problème
donc effectivement tous ces bien passé
sur le front organisation et il dit
aussi nous
partenaires sociaux et là il englobe
tout le monde on s'est montré aussi
responsable et là il dit pendant
Emmanuel Macron il parle à l'Assemblée
il parle à tout ce cirque qui est en
train de de se passer dans l'hémistique
avec ses députés irruptifs qui ne
montrent pas une image totalement
comment dire République voilà je je
j'essayais de rester aimable sur l'image
que donne l'Assemblée en ce moment il
dit et nous partenaires sociaux tous
ensemble on s'est montré responsable et
on a défendu nos convictions voilà voilà
ce qu'il dit dans un dans un premier
temps les partenaires sociaux auxquels
Emmanuel Macron ne voulait ait plus
est-ce que plus avoir à faire lorsqu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir lui il est comme
intervenir ça l'intéressait plus
cette séquence un peu malheureuse où il
a eu des mots compliqués envers les les
partenaires sociaux les corps
intermédiaires il a presque réussi son
coup parce que pendant la période des
gilets jaunes on les disait cuit mort
les sandales
se sentait méprisé on a connu cette
période d'essaye rattrapée hein c'est il
y a eu un discours des syndicats de dire
il y a pas eu aucune concertation on
nous a pas parlé on nous a pas consulté
sur cette réforme c'est moyennement vrai
ils ont été écoutés ils ont été ils ont
obtenu des choses même en amont hein oui
sur celle-ci sur cette sur cette réforme
là bien sûr il y a eu des réunions tout
un tas de réunions techniques qui ont
fait bouger des petites choses vous
savez on va voir entrer dans les détails
de tuyauterie de technique mais
évidemment il y a des petites choses qui
ont bougé et qui ont été réglées en
amont
des gros dossiers de la ligne de 64 ans
de ces choses là dont on a beaucoup plus
parler mais oui il y a eu une
consultation et il y a certains
syndicats
avoir été au moins consulté alors
Monsieur dimanche il disait autre chose
il a été très subtil sa première réponse
on s'est dit tous les deux dans le
plateau ah il dit qu'il faut continuer
en cas de vote mais il dit aussi on va
continuer à défendre l'intérêt des
salariés et on respectera je sais plus
quel était son
expression dans le cadre qui nous a
apporté à la démocratie c'est-à-dire que
si c'est voté si c'est voté demain et
ben il continuera à se battre pour
l'intérêt des salariés
et la CFDT et sur cette ligne là ce
continuera à se battre pour l'intérêt
des salariés mais on doute qu'elle
redescende dans la rue une fois que le
texte est voté alors le renverse c'est
laisser une porte de sortie
effectivement
il y a
dépend du scénario voilà c'est ça
premier scénario le vote n'est pas
favorable à la réforme la réforme ne
passe pas on repart dans d'autres
considérations deuxième option vote
classique la réforme passe
retirera en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
comprend dernier option probable
possible l'utilisation d'un 49-3 ça le
renverse
d'ailleurs eu une expression
que d'aucuns ont pu trouver malheureuse
d'ailleurs il a dit que c'était un déni
de démocratie c'était assez malheureux
comme expression parce qu'elle a 49-3
n'est pas un déni de démocratie l'option
voilà qui s'offre au gouvernement il
peut la dégainer que ce soit pas
l'option la plus glorieuse ça peut être
considéré comme tel mais en tout cas
cette réforme elle peut passer via le
49-3 elle peut être adoptée de cette
manière là ça leur plairait beaucoup
moins ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
la fameuse inter syndicale qui se réunit
ce soir et qui est assez rare ça faisait
des années
alors pas encore non ça tient ça tient
ça tient alors on sait que ça bouillonne
derrière on sait que
voilà c'est la CGT c'est
certainement un morceau de la CGT pain
mais effectivement il y a des il y a des
métiers il y a des fédérations il y a
des il y a des gens à la CGT qui
trouvent depuis le début que tout ça a
été beaucoup trop gentil qu'on s'est
beaucoup trop laissé faire que et eux
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est que ça
fissure un tout petit peu sur le le
front syndical certains ont d'ailleurs
mené des des actions de manière
totalement indépendante j'ai vu encore
qu'ils avaient couper de l'électricité
[Musique]
avant de descendre venir vous voir
qu'ils ont coupé Bregançon
voilà il y a eu les raffineries il y a
eu voilà eux eux eux ont très envie que
ça
que ça durcisse un peu bon comment on
fait pour justifier le durcissement une
fois que la réforme faite
syndicale ce soir va encore tenir
on peut le faire alors communiquer de
presse
malgré la mobilisation qui ne faiblit
pas parce qu'ils vont nous dire que ça
ne fait pas le gouvernement s'obstine
[Musique]
dans sa volonté de ne pas entendre
et de mépriser 90% des Français qui sont
contre ce recul de la retraite voilà et
donc c'est à dire que ce soir ils vont
nous proposer une nouvelle date de
manifestation
c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent attendre
demain la journée de demain peut être
plus décisive que la réunion de ce soir
on a parlé on a position
quoi qu'il arrive on continue à
oui mais comment plus
de la CGT
dans 15 jours
Philippe Martinez ne sera plus capable
de la CGT il y a plusieurs options
possibles Marie buisson parlez-nous
d'elle c'est de la
désignée favorite je sais pas si dans un
tel état là CGT c'est des ce sont des
luttes internes de fonds de forme de
lignes ceux qui trouvent que Martinez
depuis le début de son mandat n'a pas de
cogné assez fort ceux qui au contraire
c'est dans un état sur le fond assez
compliqué donc il y a
Marie buisson
qui est la l'héritière l'héritière
critiquer de toutes parts
de la CGT ah oui en fonction de la
tendance à laquelle vous appartenez tous
ceux qui trouvent elle vient d'éducation
c'est ça
première option marais buisson d'accord
deuxième option madame vergeletti oui on
voit je pense que les gens la
connaissent parce qu'on la voit beaucoup
sur les plateaux
une autre tendance au sein de la CGT et
enfin
[Musique]
monsieur
déclaré mais alors c'est très compliqué
les les élections à la CGT il s'est
déclaré mais pour l'instant
défavorisé le mouvement social j'entends
que la CGT aurait pu aller pousser plus
fort avec un Philippe Martinez lui-même
plus solide là il pèse quasiment plus
rien il est parti je vous entends et si
j'écoute quasiment plus rien parce que
quand on incarne un syndicat et c'est ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui c'était assez le
visage de la CGT une fille Martinez il a
mené son combat comme il comptait dans
le le
monnaie c'est-à-dire qu'il il l'a fait
vraiment
à sa manière et je crois pas qu'il ne
pèse plus rien aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
qu'à partir du moment où il est le
visage de la CGT il la représente et la
représentera jusqu'à ce qu'on raie ils
ont passé alors parallèlement ça c'est
moins vu sur les images la CGT mais
c'est beaucoup de temps sur ces
histoires internes ça les a oui ça les a
mobilisés ça l'a je veux pas dire que ça
les a monopolisés mais ça leur a pris du
temps
plus de formes sur leur congrès leur
ligne leur bil défendre le bilan que sur
le fond de la réforme dernière question
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché parce que les
syndicats ont une certaine manière un
coup de force ils ont mis un million et
demi de personnes dans la rue selon les
chiffres officiels plusieurs fois
pourquoi ils n'ont pas réussi à bloquer
le pays comme il l'espère qu'est-ce
qu'il manque encore au syndicat pour et
bien réussir à eux tout le pays cette
petite phrase là on va mettre la France
à l'arrêt il n'aurait pas dû d'ailleurs
quand on n'est pas certain de pouvoir
réussir à faire ce genre de choses il
faut pas le dire parce qu'après c'est
très sceptif et ça paraît comme un échec
ils ont mis beaucoup de monde dans la
rue
et en ça ils ont réussi ils ont réussi
c'est vraiment factuel ils ont en face
de des gens qui n'avaient pas
l'intention de lâcher sur les 64 ans ils
ont lâché beaucoup d'autres choses mais
n'ont pas lâché sur les 64 ans chacun
son symbole celui d'Emmanuel Macron
s'était de ne pas lâcher sur les 64 ans
à partir du moment où on a ce postulat
qui est que
l'exécutif n'allait pas lâcher sur le 64
ans
mais il pouvait descendre 6 jours 7
jours huit jours dans la rue ils ont
obtenu beaucoup de concessions par
ailleurs
beaucoup beaucoup de choses j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt des choses
mais les syndicats vraiment c'est
l'agglomération tout ça
les syndicats ont obtenu des choses
comme je vous le disais ils ont aussi
obtenu des choses en amont et ça c'est
vrai qu'on en a moins à parler
sur des choses très techniques mais très
importantes pour les carrières longues
les métiers pénibles tout ça c'est des
discussions qui existaient déjà avant
d'ailleurs
voilà maintenant on verra ce qu'on fera
dans cinq ans parce qu'il va falloir
revenir
vous redescendez quand parce qu'on y
retouche quand à cet endroit
les problèmes
Macron changerait tout ou pas peut-être
que ce sera la prochaine réforme
pas la dernière
le système par point ne résoudrait pas
forcément la question de l'équipe
financière et ça de toute façon il
faudra se reposer la prochaine fois nous
aurons tout loisir d'en reparler merci
et puis ça se trouve dans les semaines
qui viennent hein
le sujet n'est évidemment pas clos ni
aujourd'hui ni demain même si on dit que
cette journée sera décisive c'est
évidemment à faire à suivre merci
beaucoup Marie Bizot chef du service
économie France du Figaro c'est ça et on
retourne dans la manifestation Damien
canivevez on s'est quitté tout à l'heure
il y avait quelques échauffourés
quelques affrontements même on en est où
merci beaucoup écoutez le calme est
revenu ici dans le cortège parisien même
si on a l'impression que la moindre
étincelle pourrait vraiment enflammer la
situation vous le voyez sur les images
de de notre ami Julien Leclerc les
policiers sont en train d'encadrer la
manifestation et ce est si mobilise
systématiquement dès lors que le cortège
passe devant des agences bancaires qui
sont traditionnellement la cible de des
Black Blocs que l'on a l'habitude de
retrouver dans les dans les
manifestations on arrive vraiment au
terme de la manifestation c'est à dire
que là vous le voyez au bout c'est la
place d'Italie c'est là que la
manifestation va s'arrêter et on a comme
l'impression que c'est à ce moment là
que le face à face entre les forces de
l'ordre va s'intensifier pourquoi parce
que on commence à comprendre un petit
peu maintenant les codes de ces éléments
radicaux vous avez le parapluie
arc-en-ciel à côté duquel se trouve un
funigène qui éclate et très souvent
quelques minutes plus tard il y a
effectivement des des des échauffourés
la manifestation c'est c'est globalement
bien déroulé Thibault et c'est sur cette
note vraiment que je souhaite insister
c'est que il y a eu assez peu de
violences finalement à part quelques
dégradations du mobilier urbain et cette
agence d'intérim qui qui a été vandalisé
on a rencontré vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure sur nos images sur Figaro live
quelqu'un qui travaille dans le secteur
de l'énergie qui s'est dit absolument
comment dire qui s'est dit c'est dit
prêt à aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
retrait de cette réforme d'ailleurs il a
même menacé lui et son syndicat c'était
la CGT de faire des coupures
d'électricité de les intensifier voilà
et et on a vu
on saura pas ce qu'a vu Damien qui a mis
on a compris la teneur du propos
manifestation malgré les quelques images
que nous avons pu voir tout à l'heure
qui s'est plutôt bien passer on va voir
un autre de nos envoyer spéciaux Mathis
fleuret Mathis je vous pose la question
vous après avoir discuté avec plusieurs
manifestants avec plusieurs
représentants des syndicats quelle est
leur
que penses-tu vraiment que vont-ils
faire quel est ce qu'ils ont au fond
d'eux quoi après cette journée de
mobilisation et surtout à la veille du
vote sans doute décisif demain à
l'Assemblée nationale
et bien écoutez Thibault en un mot c'est
flou c'est très flou tous disent vouloir
continuer mais on ne sait pas sous
quelle forme voilà on ne sait pas
comment si ce sera des des
manifestations si ce sera des blocages
si ce sera autre chose en off un
représentant syndical me disait qu'il
était assez déçu de la mobilisation
aujourd'hui donc est-ce qu'ils peuvent
encore
réunir du monde comme sur les premières
manifestations ça l'avenir ne le dira
mais en tout cas si on peut faire un
bilan ici de de la manifestation avec
François Carpentier de notre côté
c'était très très calme très très bon
enfant contrairement à ce que Damien
Canivez vous rapporte de son côté alors
je tiens tout de même à corriger quelque
chose on a vu avec François Carpentier
ensuite des ordures sur le sur le bord
de la route de cette itinéraire bis qui
n'était pas donc totalement dégagé mais
comme c'était assez calme il n'y a pas
eu de problème
merci beaucoup Mathis fleuret oui pas
qu'on monte derrière vous bon je pense
que si on tourne la caméra puisqu'on
entend la musique mais on voit bien que
ce cortège était n'était pas aussi
fourni qu'habituellement évidemment pas
grand monde bon nous suivrons ça merci
de nous avoir été fidèle pendant cette
après-midi cette nouvelle après-midi de
manifestation alors on continue à suivre
ce qu'il se passe à l'Assemblée puisque
la CMP doit rendre un texte définitif
qui doit être voté donc demain d'abord
au Sénat et ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale on serait évidemment en direct
parce que c'est d'une certaine manière
l'avenir du pays qui se joue demain les
Français vont-ils travailler plus
longtemps ou non ça fait plusieurs
semaines même plusieurs mois même
plusieurs années que nous en parlons et
il y aura une réponse normalement quasi
définitive demain merci de nous avoir
suivis vous restez avec nous parce qu'il
y a point de vue il y a le club tout ça
c'est sur le figure live comme tous les
soirs merci de nous suivre bonne soirée